is the new m1 ultra mac studio a beast
at gaming we are gonna answer that
question in this video because i'm about
to play a bunch of games to figure out
if you can finally get really good
gaming performance so without further
ado let's jump right into it first of
all if you know you're going to be
playing apple silicon optimized games
like eve online or world of warcraft
then you're definitely going to be
taking advantage of the m1 ultra chip
and for some rosetta games we also got
really good performance like in cs go
where we got a really solid 60 up to
over 100 fps which was very nice
compared to the m1 max which did have a
little bit of glitchiness but in almost
every other game with rosetta or
crossover there were just issues where
it wasn't really utilizing the gpu all
the way especially gta 5 using crossover
my conclusion is that you should not go
higher than the m1 max chip if you're
going to be playing a lot of different
games that are not apple silicon
optimized